if central banks were football teams  mark carney would be England's star  striker when he stepped out onto the  pitch for the first time the bank of  england's new captain faced a tough tart  but his fans were cheering him on almost  straightaway he launched his first  attack the introduction of forward  guidance that's a policy tool that links  interest rates to unemployment not all  his teammates approved unemployment went  down faster than a desperate player in  the box so just six months after  announcing his guidance Mark Carney  moved the goalposts and a few months  later he moved them again fast forward  to today and the UK economy is top of  the league with the highest growth in  the g7 but with the economy hotting up  he may need to go on a counter-attack  once again central banking it's a funny  old game